I know this is your first feature film
behind the camera but you have directed
other stuff haven't used in a
documentary need in short film you've
done music video as well so how did all
that feed into this oh my goodness who's
I know my step high five no I had it her
feet into the previous stuff and I just
like making films and there were this it
was just there was a chance to make this
because I had some great actors and add
a little story and that's kind of where
it came from and it was I wanted to
experiment with the idea of with certain
acting aspects and also certain kind of
story aspects in place I tried to do all
the pacing in camera so there's only
some editing at the top and the tail of
the phone the rest of it is all shot
sequentially from start to finish and
there's pretty much no editing in it and
we're trying to do that from just
enacting the story point of view and
that was what excited me about it seeing
in that would work so your first major
film role was in a film called studs in
2006 and that was with Emmett who's in
this film what was it like directing
here and this then uh well I i directed
him in Christian Blake as well he was a
painting he was here he was a pain in
the arse and them and she would listen
to me panera listens to me and I think
every time me and them it I direct him
we have one look around and we probably
almost punch each other and then it's
fine and then I say this but i think is
Emmett just because like because i made
some reactie then I've got to tell him
what to do and I don't get what likes
now but he listens to me bizarrely where
did you prefer own kind of in the
cinematographer and Charlie Casanova
then to having to direct it you know
what here at my hand and try to cast no
because he never knew his lines he's got
so much done like and I was given a
two-man any kind of go but to do an
acting but give me a break and a gun no
just no near [ __ ] lines but now it's
kind of them it's actually fun because
then when you do because we've been cast
about
sometimes with each other like in savage
and a field of things and so then when
you just end up working as actors it's
very free because you just explore that
you don't have to worry about other
things and then because you understand
each other's actors I know it's a direct
and vice versa he knows we've done
addition day together he'd know how to
direct me because now you understand
each other are you saying that you did
this film sequentially that you went
chronologically is that how you think
you approach future films as well it was
it very specific to the inside I'd like
to make films that way think it's
important i think i just know it's
something that i'd like to do as an
actor because then you get to really
explore at the end of a scene you can
then move on to the next point and you
know how you've end at that point
otherwise sometimes you can do some
things great and then you have to kind
of change you're going to not think to
fit what you did previously and then
make this thing's match and i think he
obviously can't do that most things but
i think with this if you can I think
doona sequentially allowed people to be
free and then see where their characters
are going it wouldn't have worked not
doing its closely because they have to
kind of go to some okay now you're
really scared here and you're in a bit
of a basement and then come back and I
optimate and it doesn't the tone changes
in your bellies I don't think it works
that way I mean what's the appeal of
horror for you because it is very
intense this movie isn't it yeah it is
my granny doesn't like this phone and I
don't think I'll show my little sister
and you know I it's interesting because
what I wanted to do it it was look at
how
man can I kinda can attack another man
and kind of the worst possible thing
that a man can do to another person
which is basically disempowering someone
and murdering them and raping them and
so forth that's pretty mad like watching
some boyfriend get killed us in front of
you that's the kind of height of what
man can do to the man and then I want to
see that if that's the point that
creature would arise like it the
negative energy then brings in as
something that we actually part so the
idea that supernatural creatures are
some kind of entity is actually brought
upon by our own negative kind of
thoughts and negative energies and then
whether that had any kind of just
whether that would draw any distinction
between a good person a bad person which
of course it shouldn't because it's like
bringing in Satan because people done
some of the things I wanted to see the
juxtaposition between that the negative
negative aspect of man with with this
creature i spoke to kelly and she was
telling me that she didn't know what the
creature was going to be like until the
last minute how conscious of decision
was that on your part as a director to
keep it away from the actors that was
like what you're saying by keeping it
sequential so when I wanted to get real
reaction so everything was very real so
because we didn't I didn't I don't like
to do her so this kind of film so when
they first saw the creature that was the
first time she'd ever seen it so I think
that's a take we used as well because
she was genuinely really scared and I
think about Kelly being scared as it
makes you feel scared because she's
genuinely scared and it makes you feel
about edgy and then he kind of go oh if
I take you to much and I did get worried
sometimes because there's an awful lot
of this where it's a lot of heightened
emotions and people do go into dark
places the male actors did the girl
actress are in very dark places from
threaten I did worry a little bit
because you are pushing people to the
edges of the inside of the psyche to a
certain point so how'd you make this
sort of decisions like have I gone too
far is it not far enough it's no it's
just the right place I just ignore them
i just okay cellphone like yeah it's
fine yeah if i justjust fingers crossed
that no one does anything what's next
for you now i'm making a drama actually
a kind of a paris taxiing type film
which i'm finishing october with rebecca
night and tom harper and then i'm going
to be making another kind of very work
at the producer the inside are making a
very very heavy psychological illness
film looking at celebrity and looking at
it's it's a yeah it's about heavy film
is looking at the degradation of someone
as they begin to become famous how that
affects a psych you had they been
dependent on that that's nice talking
about fame then I mean obviously you
know for lots of things with one of the
thing to arena Boyle known for is the TV
series merlin isn't it I mean how did
that affect you I don't really think I
think maybe like Colin Farrell is famous
I think just a few people know why I'm
but everyone's really sweet and
everyone's like you know it's nice of
people actually I'm like something to do
and it's nice that people kind of a like
with Merlin people genuinely adore the
show and adore their stories of it and
that's really important and that's nice
when you can actually do something in
there and
you know it makes you were happy and you
know that's that's the whole point of
doing it that people like what we do and
you can be here I'm Ron is ringing off
last eight months I'm like it yeah what
are you what are you even doing in that
time riding horses having sword fights
getting lost in forests getting really
drunk yeah they're both in character
number and have you enjoying it as much
as you enjoyed all the other series yeah
cuz have you watched it it's good fun
yeah yeah you know everyone's happens
really [ __ ] cool it's all very
chilled and they're all really nice
people to work in Bradley and Colin and
Tom and it's a really nice group of
people pentas its way it should be it's
fun
you